[Music]
what does one win mean to a man who's
already won it all he's looking to close
it out with the perfect oh yeah that's
it
ceo 2019 champion give it up for me
snap he's been playing well his entire
life ever since he's touched a
controller for tekken he's been good at
it i didn't he didn't even have a bottle
he had an arcade stick with a korean
lever in that bad boy playing kick it
knee has been playing tekken for two
decades and he's won dozens of
tournaments at the highest level of play
in one of the most competitive fighting
games in the world now he's got the
right health
[Applause]
knee was already considered a god of
tekken he had the reputation the skill
and every win he needed to secure his
legacy every win except one the tekken 7
evo world championship knee had trophies
sure but the big one eluded him after
tekken 7 took the series to the top of
the fgc
knee just couldn't win the most
important title in fighting games it's
turning point for satan right now he's
trying to become evil champion oh
the counter his jab he does it safe evo
2016 tekken 7fr champion jdc are on the
stage to celebrate with them he is fired
up in third knee
with the scene changing new players
coming in to challenge him and tekken 7
on the verge of fading away
it seemed like ni's last chance would be
his hardest fight yet
so
[Music]
so what would one more win mean well to
me
it meant everything everyone at home we
are watching a living legend
me one of the most storied players in
tech in competitive history
folks before we get into the video i
want to ask you to please sub to the
channel and turn on notifications if you
haven't done it yet if you want more ftc
content like this video then please let
us know do all of that yell at us
because we want to bring you the best
stories from the fgc also if you haven't
done it yet head over to twitch.tv score
esports and give us a follow over there
we are going live all the time now and
you don't want to miss a stream okay so
you've already heard me say this but it
really can't be overstated me is the god
of tekken he dedicated his life to the
game from the moment he started playing
it it'd be hard to find anyone more
devoted to the scene than him a lot of
people consider him to be like the best
of all time primarily due to his
longevity how long he's been around
as one of the top players in the game
i don't think there's anybody that's
been around
as consistent and you know as strong as
he has been over the last
what 20 years i don't think it is
anybody that's matched that but beyond
his passion for the game knee is also
incredible at it his play style is
extremely technical yet flawless and
back in 2013 knee showed america just
how good he was by winning tekken tag
tournament 2 at evo what he wants right
here oh that's gonna be oh my god oh my
god bronson loses and gets second place
south korea's cafe it's knee takes it
but tekken in 2013 was a far cry from
what it would become shortly after the
release of tekken 7. tekken 7 changed
the competitive tekken landscape the
series was always popular casually but
travel was expensive and prize pools
were relatively small making
international competition pretty rare a
few korean and japanese players came
over to america every once in a while
but those instances were few and far
between until tekken 7 came out the game
was a massive hit and year after year
tournaments got bigger and bigger
international competition became common
and that meant players were constantly
leveling up and raising the bar but as a
result of just how much better everyone
was getting
knee fell short at evo can't need make
the comeback again it's turning point
for sane right now he's trying to become
evil champion oh
jab he does it safe evo 2016 tekken 7fr
champion jdc are on the stage to
celebrate with them
oh there it is was a tall order the
handshake wow that's what i love to see
the sportsmanship and of course the
legendary going home third place here at
evo 2017. knee did well but second and
third place weren't good enough for the
god of tekken so he kept grinding these
mechanics were still top tier and his
character pool continued to grow making
him one of the scariest players in the
game by 2018 knee was back to dominating
the scene and he kicked the year off
with a big win at evo japan it's gonna
be very very close though and the oaky
behind the sonic bank the second hit
[Music]
knee is your champion for evo japan 2018
knee took home eight trophies in 2018
but the evo world title still eluded him
due to schedule conflicts and the fact
that evo 2018 wasn't part of the tekken
world tour that year knee decided to
stay home with his family missing out on
another shot at a main stage victory and
sure maybe he thought he'd have his shot
next year but unfortunately for me in
everything changed
[Music]
up until this point south korea was the
most dominant force in tekken sure
europe nna produced some brilliant
talent over the years but nothing
compared to the likes of chanel jdcr
saint and of course knee but in 2019 a
region that wasn't on anyone's radar
came out of nowhere to shock everyone oh
boy oh god and that's it wow
he gets beaten by our speed by arsenal
3-0
oug tournament
congratulations to our salon from
pakistan our salon ash was the underdog
story of a lifetime pakistan wasn't
known as a tekken powerhouse region but
by winning evo japan our salon put his
country on the map in the lead-up to evo
2019 knee already had two run-ins with
him and the god of tekken lost both
times and at evo
knee once again came up short
that was a crazy trade arseland
cementing his position as the best
tekken player on the planet untouchable
it was the third time knee made top
three at evo for tekken 7. and for a
third time he lost
so evo disappeared along with basically
every other offline event making these
chances of winning it all in mandalay
bay pretty slim but despite the lack of
tournaments and the fact that he was now
in his mid-30s knee continued to do what
he always did grind tekken and then in
2022 knee finally got another chance eva
was back
and he was ready
despite being one of the oldest players
in the bracket knee was playing some of
the best tekken the world had ever seen
he's a monster yeah he is not scared
unrelenting that is the crazy part
against the brian player where you're
thinking to yourself i don't want to get
counted here because every counter is a
launcher but this sense
does not care
holy moly me has come to play
knee was playing like a man possessed
dominating his bracket all the way to
top eight but look at that though he is
straight away
not letting kenya even breathe right now
that's fifty percent gone back for just
stopping all of his offense oh
that's it that's it that's it he's dead
he's dead he has to be oh
what is happening right now dominance
from knee as he moves into tomorrow's
top eight at the arena on the winner's
side evo 2022
knees victory wasn't guaranteed though
arson was also in top 8 along with his
teammate and countryman khan but before
facing down the next generation of
tekken talent knee had to bring down his
own countryman mo il despite being a
lesser known contender mo eel had been
grinding in the scene for years and
proved his worth on his way to top eight
but me didn't even break a sweat it's
the craziest best knee i've seen in a
long time literally every top player
he's played has looked bad again he is
stronger than ultra hard computer can't
find any big opening he's not letting
him have nothing back tempo and that
will be enough me 2-0 over moyo he's
going to the winner's final to face khan
ni's next hurdle was a pakistani player
but this time it wasn't our salon ash it
was khan arsan once said that he was
just one person in a deep community of
pakistani tekken players some of whom he
considered better than him and khan was
one of those players this was khan's
first ever evo and he defeated again
anakin and super akuma the best players
from japan north america and europe to
get to knee in the winner's finals he
was the pakistani prodigy a favorite to
win it all but knee had the experience
not only has he been playing for two
decades but he spent much of 2019
traveling to pakistan to play tekken he
practiced with and learned from the best
of the best in that region and he was
ready to put that practice to the test
we gotta talk about right now the legend
need
fighting for his first tekken 7 title
here knee hasn't lost to anybody in this
tournament he's made everybody look bad
but neither has khan khan has not lost
to anyone here at evo 2022 they're both
here undefeated all right khan find the
back you do just do it just believe max
mo to go back to go off the steps he
should be able to close it out he should
be there
there you go kahn on the board one a
piece
i love the single back because he's
trying to get me throughout that parry
again back
how is he this good with that move i
don't know
but khan right now he's got raising two
meters with geese he's gonna do it again
he's he's aiming for it of course at the
pixel
depowered not gonna happen today
knee
two to one now
in this winner's final needs one more to
get to the grand finals
oh he's delayed yeah nice punish gets
the knock down the follow-up as well got
some extra damage
that could have been the worst mistake
we've seen in the set so that's huge but
he still has a big lead big lead and a
bar meter knee chipping back away at
this lead though he could have had the
winning mix up though it could have been
it could have been but not if that needs
almost gone up the counter the wall's
right there though he's gonna lift last
chance caught down two
knees he's going to the grand finals of
evo 2022
it was close but knee prevailed sending
khan down to losers but pakistan's hero
bounced back beating arslan the
defending evo champion to earn his run
back against me the grand finals were
set on one side an up-and-coming star
from an up-and-coming region looking to
win his very first evo and cement
pakistan as tekken's greatest superpower
on the other side was me a 37 year old
veteran of the game a man who's attended
countless tournaments and was looking to
do more than win for his country knee
had his legacy on the line could he do
it or would it just be another second
place
here they are setting up on the stage
for our grand finals
knee on the winner's side of the bracket
khan fresh off of eliminating arsene ash
if you're caught how are you going to
approach here again with the deficit he
does have to meet her but does he want
to use it this early
oh my gosh yo 10 seconds it's gonna be
so dangerous beautiful stuff we owe the
conversion beautiful
reflect elbow range hard after here we
go is it enough damage mark isn't it i
can't tell i don't know it's going to be
close
you thought you had me you thought you
had the lead you ain't got nothing yet
and now rage want to get for knee khan
has one bar to me to work with back kept
going to nothing single jab he's baiting
it out that's beautiful
see what he does he has to hide that
this is huge he might get the wall he's
going to get the walls of his stuff he
might come back he might be here
ten seconds about left right now he's
close he's got one more bar neat can be
champion in five seconds he's got the
lead he's got the lead he's gonna do it
and city two one knee is york tekken 7
champion and evil 20 22
after years of coming up short knee
finally earned his tekken 7 eva win the
money the trophy all of that didn't
matter he won something much bigger up
against younger talent endless ambition
and relentless skill knee didn't just
prove that he's the greatest tekken
player of all time he proved that he is
the one true god of tekken now
and forever he's kind of like in a spot
where
he's he's he's set the bar and he's
raising it for anyone he's raising it
not only for himself but anyone that
might come you know 10 20 years down the
road kind of
he's the gold standard now
um
after so many years so many years of
trying to win this tournament he has
finally done it there is no no other
player that is more deserving than me
and finally gets his evil championship
for tekken 7. oh man
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this then hit the sub
button and ring the notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else hit up our twitter
instagram facebook and tick tock
you